Herkese merhaba Tuğba ben Tuğba ile Çok
teşekkür ediyorum organizasyon için hem
düzenleyen arkadaşlarıma hem de
konuşmacı arkadaşlarıma eşitsizlikler
ince konuşulacak konu çok çok fazla
elbette ama ben konuşmamı kadın sen
yaparsın Hikayem bu süreçte
öğrendiklerimi fark ettikleri üzerine
biraz kurdum rakamlar istatistikten çok
fazla Elbette iş dünyasındaki kadın ve
girişimcilik dünyasındaki kadına ilişkin
Ama bu rakamları hiç girmeyeceğim 8mart
bestesiyle sıkça zaten birçok kanaldan
bunları duyacağız Ben önce kadın sen
yaparsın sürecimi başlatan bunu
tetikleyen konuyu bir anlatmak istiyorum
minik bir hikaye ve uzun yıllar
gazetecilik yaptım ben ve uzmanlık
sayfası hazırladım yönetim sayfaları
yazdım Dolayısıyla yazıyla uğraşan
herkes gibi benimde video bunları
derleyip toplayıp kitaba dönüştürmek
gibi hayalim vardı ama yönetim çok
bu alan pazarlama insan kaynakları
stratejisi Finans bir sürü şeyi içeriyor
ne odaklanmış ama tam olarak karar
verememiştim şöyle bir şey oldu Ben
İstanbul'da yaşıyorum Kadıköy bir
semtinde yaşıyorum son derece İşlek bir
mahallede yaşıyorum kadının hayatının
içinde çok fazla yer aldığı ve rolünün
çok büyük olduğu bir yerde yaşıyorum Bir
gün Evimden çıktım ki yıllardır bu evde
oturuyorum Madem de çok fazla esnaf
vardır ana cadde doğru yürürken bir
hayal canlandı gözümde böyle nalburun
önüne tabletine 60 oturan bir kadın
kuruyemişin önde leblebileri kavuran bir
kadın ve bu hayale birlikte yüzünde
güller açtığını fark ettim ama daha
sonra şöyle gerçek dünyaya ve etrafına
bir baktığımda bu kadar esnafın olduğu
bir mahallede ve bu kadar kadının
hayatını içinde olduğu bir semtte hiç
kadın esnaf olmadığını fark ettim sadece
markette kasada çalışan kasiyer genç
kadınlar ve kuaför
bu işte Kaş alan kadınlar vardı çalışan
olarak dedim ki Tuğba Madem yüzünü bu
kadar gülümsetti o zaman ne
odaklanacağız belli oldu aslında benim
kadınsa yaparsa İyi oğlum kadın esnaf
hayali ile başlayan bir süreçte önce
kitapçıkta daha sonra benim için çok
büyük bir şans olan kadınsa yaparsın
buluşmayı organize etmeye başladım
tamamen bağımsız bir sosyal gelişimde bu
hiç kimseden bir deste kalmadım ya da
kaynak almadım bir süreç kendi yağıyla
kavrulan organizasyonlarda İstanbul'da
başladı daha sonra Türkiye'nin farklı
şehirlerinde İskenderun Bursa Ankara
Antakya gibi iş yapan ve iş yapmayı
düşünen kadınların bir araya geldiği hem
hikayelerini anlattıkları hem de
birbirimize nasıl destek oluruz bunları
konuştuğumuz biraz da eğitimleri Noldu
organizasyonlar the 80 üzerinde
organizasyon oldu pandemi ya kadar
pandemi Dede iki üç tane Zoom
organizasyonu yaptı kadınsan yapar
son yolculuğuna buluşmalara girdiğimde
Aslında kadınsa yaparsın isminin Ne
kadar etkili bir isim olduğunu fark
ettim yani kitabın ismine koyduğum zaman
da güzel bir isim diye düşünmüştüm ama
bu organizasyonlar için sosyal medyadan
reklamlar verdiğim zaman organizasyon
altını ve içeriğine okumadan daha sadece
kadın sen yaparsın İsmini gördüm ve sizi
aramak istedim diyen çok kadınla
karşılaştım inanılmaz hikayeler dinledim
Tabii ki girişimcilik süreçlerine
ilişkin Ben kadın sen yaparsın derken
iki tane amacım vardı aslında bir tanesi
motive etmek ilham vermek cesaret vermek
ikincisi de sen kadınsan zaten yaparsın
kısmıydı Çünkü kadınlar aynı anda birçok
şeyi fotoğraf bilme yeteneğine sahip bir
de bir kadına dört duvarın arasında
koysan da mutlaka üretir kadın ama reçel
yapar ama salça yapar ama el işi yapar
bir şey üretir önemli olan o duvarların
dışına çıkmasına sağlamak Aslında ve ne
kadar ihtiyacımız olduğunu fark
biz birbirimize yaparsın demeye
birbirimizi yüreklendirme yen diğerine
elini uzatmaya ve uzattığında oraya
Gerçekten samimiyetle tutacak olan
ellerin olduğunu görmeye eve ben çok
şanslıydım organizasyonda binlerce
kadınla karşılaştım hepsiyle iletişimi
sürüyor hiç Kadın kadının kurdudur diye
bir şey görmedim doğrusu hep birbirine
destek olan ve dayanışma içinde olan
kadınlar söz konusu oldu ve hala da bir
aradalar ve iletişim halindeler gelelim
işin girişimcilik kısmına kadınlar neler
yaşıyorlar girişimcilik sürecinde Evet
de iş kurma sürecinin kadın için de
erkek için de benzer zorlukları var
sıfırdan bir şey kurmak bir marka
oluşturmak finansman kaynaklarına
erişmek o içi geliştirme pazarlar bulmak
ürün geliştirmek gibi kadın için de
erkek için de benzer zorluklar sözkonusu
ancak Hem benim bu altı yıl
o odaklanmış Olan gözlemlerim kadına
yönelik hem de yapılmış olan bir sürü
araştırmanın ortaya koyduğu şeyler var
kadının erkeğe göre erkekten farklı
olarak yaşadığı sorunlara ilişkin
bunlardan bir tanesi toplumdaki
kalıplaşmış roller ve Ataerkil Yapı bir
diğeri aile aile desteği Ya da aile
Köfteyi de diyebiliriz bu aslında Sadece
kadın için de erkek için de oluyor bazen
en yakınlarımız koruma içgüdüsüyle işte
yapar da başarısız olursa bunu
beceremeyince Jack şimdi üzülecek Ondan
sonra hayal kırıklığı yaşayacak diye en
az destek veren ya da hiç destek
vermeyen taraf oluyorlar iş yükü Çünkü
kadından beklenen çok fazla şey var
kadın birçok şeyi idare etmek durumunda
çocukları evin düzenine yakın aileyiz
sosyal ilişkileri arkadaşlarla olan
iletişimi Bunların hepsi aslında bir
şekilde kadının üzerinden ve bazen şu
oluyor
ve eğitim düzeyi yüksek İş hayatın
içerisinde yıllarca yer alan kişilerde
dahi gözlemlediğim bir şey bu şunu
unutuyoruz bir şeyler kendi çevremizde
yaşanmıyor olsada Ailemizde hiç böyle
yaşanmamış olsa da geldi çalıştığımız
şirketlerde bu cinsiyet ayrımını
yaşamamış olsak da biz görmüyoruz diye
sorunlar Yok değil diye bir şey yok
kadın girişimciliğine yönelik sorunlar
Sadece bizim ülkemizde değil dünyanın
her yerinde yaşanıyor Biraz sonra bir
iki tane çarpıcı örnek tensa bahsetmek
istiyorum özellikle finansmanla ilgili
Prens al kaynaklara erişim de sıkıntı
yaşanıyor Dediğim gibi biraz sonra bir
örnek vereceğim buna dair güvensizlik
yani kadının bir erkeğin fotoğraf
bileceği işleri kurtaramayacağı na dair
bir alt güvensizlik söz konusu birtakım
kodlar var becerebilecek mi yapabilecek
mi Çocukları idare edebilecek mi
yeterince dakika yarışmak mı acaba
kendisine anlayabilecek mi işte
mı gelecek mi acaba bu işi
gerçekleştirirken gibi bir de kamusal
alanda kendini ifade etme yetersizliği
maalesef Bizler kamusal alanda ya da
Siyasette yer almaktan çekildiğimiz için
bu birçok eğitimli insan için de söz
konusu sadece kadınlar için değil karar
verme mekanizması içerisinde yer
almıyoruz geçen sene kadınsa yaparsın
kapsamında 8 Mart'ta bir çalışma
yapmıştım Çok bildiğimiz bir tablo bu
ama ismi de bir karar ver Karar verdim
bütün organizasyonlara Borsa İstanbul
SPK maliye vesaire bunların üst üste
yönetimlerine kadını destekliyorum diyen
Türkiye Odalar Borsalar Birliği de buna
dahil olmak üzere hiçbir yere maalesef
üst yönetiminde Yani karar veren
mekanizmalarında kadının yer almadığını
gördüm sıfırla bir arasında en fazlası
iki tane kadın olduğu organizasyonlar
Dolayısıyla kadının karar alma
mekanizmalarının içerisinde daha çok yer
alması Bu anlamda bir
bu el uzatma mız oldukça önemli İleride
kariyer planlaması yaparken siz de
lütfen karar verme mekanizması
içerisinde olma yönünde de kararlarınızı
kullanın diyorum finansmana erişimde
yetersizlikle ilgili bir sayfalık şuraya
anlatmak istiyorum Daha sonra buralara
dönerim bir iki tane Araştırmadan örnek
vereceğim bence çok çarpıcı Bu bir tane
üniversitenin ya da bir tane kurumun
yaptığı bir araştırma değil bir derleme
yazısı yapmıştım bir zamanlar birçok
araştırmaya ve rapora baktım bunu
yaparken crunchbase Harvard Business
school Kolombiya varsın insaat gibi
dünyanın önde gelen üniversitelerinin iş
okulların özellikle yaptığı çalışmalar
Bunlar Amerika Birleşik Devletleri
Avrupa ülkeleri ve hatta Kuzey Avrupa
ülkeleri Bu da risk sermayesi şirketleri
ne bakmışlar risk sermayedarları
girişimcilere fon sağlayan kurumlardır
Normalde bunlar
Ben sadece ne bakması gerekir Bu iş bana
para kazandırır mı buraya yaptığım
yatırım bana ne kadar geri dönecektir
buna bakması gerekir bunların yaptıkları
görüşmeleri ve video ile kaydetmişler ve
yüzlerce görüşme kadın ve erkek
girişimcilerle yapılan görüşmeler ve bu
görüşmelerdeki yaklaşım ve davranış
biçimlerini analiz etmişler be şu
görülmüş yapılan analizlerde ilk
söylemiştim Amerika Birleşik
devletleri'ndeki Amerika Birleşik
Devletleri'nde toplam girişimcilerin
yüzde 36'sı kadınlar oluşturuyor Aslında
ve risk sermayesi şirketlerinden onlara
düşen pay sadece yüzde iki oranında
erkeklerin Yüzde altmış yedisine teşvik
odaklı kadınların Yüzde altmış 6'sına
ise tedbir odaklı sorular sorulduğu fark
edilmiş bu eminim ki bilinçli bir şey
değil aslında daha tehlikeli bir yer
bilinçli bir şey olmaması bizim bir dışı
olarak geliştirdiğimiz şeyler ve yıllar
o zihnimizde yerleşmiş olan kodlamalar
bu bilinçli bir Davranıştan daha daha
zor bir şey açılmasını daha zor bir şey
bizlerin göremeyeceği bir şey Belki
belki birkaç nesil sonra
düzelebileceğini olumlu pozitif yönde
elenirse düzeltebilecek bir şey belki
Çünkü bu kodların temizlenmesi gerekiyor
zihnimizden ne demek istiyorum teşvik
odaklı ve tedbir odaklı sorular derken
mesela erkeklere sorulan sorularda aynı
sorulara ama ben sizinle konuşurken
bambaşka bir üslup izleyebilirim Sizinle
konuşurken bambaşka bir sürpriz
diyebilirim Aslında sonra aynıdır
nihayetinde kapsam aynıdır ama size o
soruyu sonuç tarzına Sizi başka bir
tarafa yönlendirebilirim Dolayısıyla Bu
sorularda da mesela erkeklere potansiyel
kazançlarla ilgili sorular sorulduğu
görülmüş Yani ben size şunu diyorum
karşında bir erkek girişimci varken
diyorum ki önümüzdeki beş yıl içerisinde
işini nereye taşımaya hayal ediyorsun
bunu nasıl büyütme
Ne diyorsun hangi yeni pazarlara
gireceksin ürünleri nasıl çeşitlendi RC
X'in işi büyütmeye ve kazançlara ilişkin
şeyler soruyorum teşvik odaklı ama kadın
girişimcilere sorulan sorular Biraz önce
dediğim gibi tedbir odaklı tedbir odaklı
daha kastettiğimiz de şu bir kriz
yaşansa ne gibi önlemler alırsınız Ya da
sizin sektörünüz de bir sıkıntı ortaya
çıktığı zaman işinizi nasıl kurtarmayı
düşünüyorsunuz nasıl tasarruf yaparsınız
hangi alanlardan çekebilirsiniz
dolayısıyla bir soruyu soru şekliniz de
aslında alacağınız cevapları da
etkilemiş oluyorsunuz ve dolayısıyla
soruyu soru şekliniz de aslında olayın
sonucunda belirlemiş oluyorsunuz bu
noktada erkeklerin finansmana erişimi
çok daha fazla oluyor yine bazı
araştırmacılar şunu söylüyor diyorlar ki
bu risk sermayesi şirketlerinin çoğunu
sahibi erkek Bu yüzden daha o erkekler
kulübü mantı
bu E biraz daha erkeklere fon vermeye
şeyler eğilimliler ama Bloomberg
kapsamlı bir araştırma yapmıştı analiz
yapmış ve bunun böyle olmadığını
söylüyor bunun belki özellikle isveçte
yaptığı bir araştırma ve analiz yine
böyle incelenmiş kadınların sahibi ve
ortağı olduğu risk sermayesi
şirketlerinin de kadınlara çok az son
verdiklerini gösteriyor ve Kadınların
erkekler kadar bu işi fotoğraf rica
düşüncesinde dediğim gibi Özellikle bu
bilincimiz de ki bir takım kodlamalar
burada çok etkili oluyor bu acaba baktım
var mı Ben önce bu finansmana erişim ile
ilgili bahsetmek istedim buradan Yine
diğer konulara döneyim birazdan şey
demiştim ki kadın girişimcinin önündeki
en önemli Hadi kaplar bir kalıplaşmış
roller ve Ataerkil Yapı kadına yüklenmiş
olan roller özellikle evli ise ve çocuğu
varsa
Ya anne rolü o eve düzenini sağlayacak
olan kadın rolü Elbette kadına
girişimcilik de biraz zorluyor
rollerimize Tabii ki üstümüzden çıkarıp
atalım demiyorum ama denge ve eşitlik
gerekiyor burada bir erkek bir işi
batırdığı zaman ya da o işte başarısız
olduğu zaman bir iş batırmış oluyor ve
işte başarısız olmuş oluyor ama kadın bu
girişime ilk adımı atarken bu rollerin
baskısıyla ve etraftan duyduğu
söylemlerle şunu da düşünüyor Ben bu işi
yapamazsam başka suçlamalarla karşı
karşıya kalacağım yarın öbür gün bana
denecek ya da deniyor ki bak işte Ne
oldu bu işte uğraştım buna vakit ayırdın
çocuğunun dersleri kötüye gitti Okulu
kötüye gitti olursa kocanın gönlü
başkasına kayarsa evliliğini yürüttüğü
demedin ya da kocanla ilgilenmedin
ailenle ilgilenmedin gibi suçlamalarla
da karşı karşıya kalma
İyi ki söz olmuşsa bazen sırf bugüne
bilinç dışımızda olan şeyler Aslında
bunlara yazılı olarak engel olarak
koymuyoruz belki ama biz de o ilk adımı
atmaktan alıkoyuyor ve gerçekten bu
noktada dayanışmak çok önemli her alanda
bu böyle biraz önce Ramazan beyin
anlattığı ve bizim fark etmemizi
sağlayan başka bir açıyla bakmamızı
sağlayan Belki de konuşmasında da olduğu
gibi kadın girişimciliğine de bu çok
önemli çünkü girişimcilik insanın
kendisine tek başına hissettiği bir
süreç zaten yapabileceğim ve
yapamayacağımı böyle çok dalgalanan bir
ruh hali söz konusu Evet ben bu işi
yapabiliyorum Hayır ben bu işi
yapamıyoruz diye gün içerisinde bir sürü
dalgalanma yaşanıyor bu süreçte
dayanışmaya çok ihtiyaç var yapabilirsin
diyecek Birine çok ihtiyaç var
işbirliklerine çok ihtiyaç var
Dolayısıyla kadınlar arasındaki ağların
iş ağlarının kuvvetlenmesine çok
ne var Erkekler tarih seni çok uzun
yıllarından itibaren bu ağları ekonomik
birlikleri Ve işbirliklerini oluşturmuş
durumdalar tabii ki burada kadın erkek
ayrıldın diye bir şey demiyorum Elbette
Ben hayatımda kendi hayatımda çok büyük
Bu anlamda eşitsizlik yaşadığımı
düşünmedim ama bazen biz bunları normal
eleştiriyoruz da tabii ki yaşamadığını
zannediyorsun ama aslında yaşadığın bir
sürü şey oluyor Daha sonra farkediyorsun
bunu Çünkü toplumun içerisinde zaten
sana davranışların normal zannediyorsun
normal zannettiğimiz ama aslında
eşitsizlik olan çok fazla unsur da var
ama bir araya geldikçe birbirimizin
hikayesini Dinledikçe hayatımızın sadece
kendi hayatımızdan ibaret olmadığını
hayatımızın sadece kendi eğitim
aldığımız okullardan ibaret olmadığını
kendi ailemizden ibaret olmadığını fark
etmemiz gerekiyor başka bir dünya başta
yaşamlar zorluklar yaşayan kadınlar ya
da insanlar
biz birbirimize ancak dinleyerek
birbirinizi yüreklendirmek birbirimize
çeşit alet vererek kendimiz o sorunu
yaşamazsak dahi O sorunun çözümünün bir
parçası olmaya çalışarak ne
yapabiliyorsak gelip geçici Olduğumuz bu
dünyada belki minik bir iz bırakarak
Bunların içinde yer almamız gerektiğini
çok değerli olduğuna inanıyorum ben
başta panelimi dediğiniz için ve biraz
bahsettiğimiz için çok minik
bahsedeceğim pandemi sürecin artısı
doldu eksisi doldu kadın girişimciliğin
de artan ev yükü ve iş yükü evden
çalışma evden eğitim nedeniyle
kadınların özellikle evden bir şeyler
üretip satan kadınların işini
zorlaştırdı ne uğraşıyorsun bununla evin
düzeni ile uğraş gibi söylemler çok
fazla olduğu için bu işlerini ikinci
plana attılar ve biraz daha çalışma
hayatından çekilmeye başladılar Ama bir
yandan da online eğitimler e-ticaret
imkanının artması bugüne kadar e-ticaret
yapmaktan korkan Instagram'dan
bu tanıtmaktan korkan kadınlar için çok
cesaretlendirici ve teşvik edici oldu
online eğitimlerinde Kendimizi
geliştirmek için birçok fırsat sunduğunu
düşünüyorum birçok kadında bunu
değerlendirdi kendisini ve işini
geliştirmek için olaya fırsatlar
tarafından bakmakta fayda var ve bu
şekilde ilerlemekte fayda var diye
düşünüyorum